>> Dana: SO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION GETTING COLD OUT
IGNORING WHAT PARENTS WANT WHILE
PUSHING EQUITY AGENDA IN
CLASSROOMS.
REPUBLICAN GLENN YOUNGKIN
DEFENDING THE PARENTS RIGHTS HE
INSTITUTED IN VIRGINIA.
>> PARENTS HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT TO BE ENGAGED AND THEIR
PARENTS LIVES AND OH, BY THE
WAY, PARENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
HAVE PARENTS ENGAGED IN THEIR
LIFE.
WE NEED TO FIX THE WRONG.
THEY DO NOT BELONG TO THE
STATEMENT FAMILIES.
SO THESE MOST IMPORTANT
DECISIONS, STEP ONE, ENGAGE
PARENTS AND OUT TO THE EXCLUSION
OF A TRUSTED TEACHER OR ADVISOR
TO MAKE SURE THAT PARENTS ARE
INVOLVED IN THEIR CHILDREN'S
LIVES.
THIS IS NOT CONTROVERSIAL.
>> Dana: MEANWHILE BIDEN'S
EDUCATION SECRETARY COMING UNDER
FIRE FOR PARENT GROUPS AND
EDUCATION HANDING OUT MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON WELLNESS AND
EQUITY INSTEAD OF ACTUAL
ACADEMICS.
IT IS BECAUSE SECRETARY CARDONA
WANTS TO REIMAGINE OUR SCHOOLS
WITH MORE EQUITABLE LENS AND
RAISE THE BAR FOR HOW WE SERVE
STUDENTS WHO OFTEN GET LEFT
BEHIND.
GREG, NO ONE IS AGAINST HELPING
STUDENTS GET LEFT BEHIND.
>> Greg: I AM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: EQUITABLE LENS IS THE
REASON.
>> Greg: IT IS NO SURPRISE
DECLINE IN LITERACY IS
COINCIDING WITH THIS EQUITY
CRUSADE.
BECAUSE EQUITY IS NOT ABOUT
GIVING EVERYBODY A LEG UP BUT
MAKING FROM ABOVE AS
KAMALA HARRIS SAID, EVERYBODY
WILL END UP IN THE SAME PLACE.
THAT IS WHAT SHE SAYS SO IF JACK
CAN'T READ, IT IS BETTER TO MAKE
SURE JILL DOES NOT READ MUCH
BETTER THAN HE DOES.
THAT IS EQUITY, THE OPPOSITE OF
OPPORTUNITY AND YOU SEE THIS
EVERYWHERE.
GETTING RID OF GRADING SCALES,
HONORS CLASSES, EXTRA CREDIT AND
SOME PEOPLE NOT LOOKING AT
S.A.T.S ANYMORE.
IT IS BECAUSE THOSE THINGS
REVEAL ANY QUALITY AND OUTCOMES,
RIGHT, THAT WHICH IS THE ESSENCE
OF FREEDOM.
PEOPLE ARE FREE ENOUGH TO
EXERCISE THEIR INDIVIDUAL
DIFFERENCES.
THERE WAS GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
OUTCOMES, RIGHT?
ANY TIME YOU TRY TO FLATTEN THAT
THING DOWN, WHICH IS EQUITY,
THAT IS AN ATTACK ON FREEDOM.
IT IS IN HUMAN.
SO YOU WILL SEE PEOPLE GET WORSE
AND WORSE SCORES BECAUSE --
>> Dana: GLENN YOUNGKIN
RUNNING HIS BIGGEST APPLAUSE
LINE AND I WILL MAKE SURE
ADVANCED MATH IS OFFERED AT
EVERY SCHOOL.
A HUGE APPLAUSE.
JESSICA, EDUCATION DOESN'T
ALWAYS SHOW UP IN THE POLLS AS A
TOP ISSUE, ESPECIALLY WHEN CRIME
AND INFLATION ARE TOP OF MIND.
BUT FROM YOUR RESEARCH OR
KNOWLEDGE, DO YOU THINK THE
DEMOCRATS ARE VULNERABLE ON THIS
ISSUE?
>> Jessica: WE ARE DOWN TO A
SIX-POINT ADVANTAGE AND WELL
INTO THE DOUBLE DIGITS.
SO OBVIOUSLY, THERE HAS BEEN
MOVEMENT THERE.
I THINK GLENN
YOUNGKIN, OBVIOUSLY, A PRETTY
GOOD PLAYBOOK ABOUT REPUBLICANS
ON HOW TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
I TALKED ON THE SHOW BEFORE, CRT
OR WOKE POLICIES WAS THE
ISSUE, HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
BRASS TACKS OF GETTING KIDS IN
SCHOOL MASK LISTS TO BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH TEACHERS AND TO LEARN.
HE WASN'T TALKING ABOUT ALL THE
OTHER PERIPHERY YOU'LL STUFF
THAT WOULD PERSUADE A MODERATE
OR MAYBE CONSERVATIVE DEMOCRAT
TO COME OUT AND SUPPORTED
REPUBLICAN.
I THINK THE IMPLICATIONS OF
TERRY McAULIFFE'S COMMENT
DURING THE RACE WHERE HE SAID
THE KIDS DON'T BELONG AND THEY
ARE PART OF THE SYSTEM IS GOING
TO RIPPLE POTENTIALLY FOR
DECADES.
RIGHT?
THIS IS SO FUNDAMENTAL TO HELP
PARENTS FEEL ABOUT THEIR
EDUCATION, NO MATTER WHO YOU
VOTE FOR.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE
RUNNING AGGRESSIVELY ON IT TO
TALK ABOUT HOW PUBLIC EDUCATION
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS CONSISTENTLY
FALL BACK ON "WE WANT TO GIVE
YOU OPTIONS.
TAKE IT $7,000 AND GO TO AN
PRIVATE SCHOOL."
>> Dana: JUDGE, WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THAT?
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON'T
KNOW.
IT IS NOT JUST WHAT
TERRY McAULIFFE SAID, BUT IT
WAS REALLY AN INSIGHT INTO WHAT
THE TEACHERS UNION OUR THINKING.
THERE IS SOMETHING CALLED IN
LOCO PARENTIS AND THAT MEANS
OBVIOUSLY THE PARENT IS NOT
AROUND, THE TEACHER CAN BE THERE
TO EDUCATE THE CHILDREN.
BUT THAT IS IN NO WAY SUPERIOR
TO OR EQUAL TO A PARENT.
SO THE CONCEPT THAT WE HAVE TO
LITERALLY FIGHT FOR A PARENTAL
RIGHTS POLICY IS ABSURD.
IT IS PART OF THIS WHOLE
MOVEMENT THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING WITH WOKENESS AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND WITH THE
PANDEMIC.
YOU KNOW, THE KIDS ARE NOT
LEARNING.
CRIME IS GOING UP.
WE DON'T HAVE AS MUCH MONEY.
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO IN A
HANDBASKET.
WE HAVE TO PULL BACK AT SOME
POINT.
WHETHER OR NOT IT IS GOING TO
CHARTER SCHOOL, OR TAKING YOUR
MONEY AND THE MONEY TO FOLLOW
THE CHILD, THE SCHOOL DOES NOT
OWN THE KIDS BUT THEY THINK THEY
DO.
THEY GET MORE MONEY THE MORE
KIDS THEY HAVE.
LET'S NOT KID EACH OTHER.
LET'S NOT KID EACH OTHER THAT
THE BILLIONS THAT THEY GOD, THEY
HAVE NOT SPENT YET.
THEY SHOULD HAVE TO GIVE THAT
MONEY BACK.
AND WHAT DID YOU DO WITH IT AND
WE WANT IT BACK IF YOU DIDN'T
NEED IT.
THE SCHOOLS ARE OPEN.
>> Dana: DO YOU THINK THE
SCHOOLS -- MAYBE IT'S NOT A
COMPLETE ADVANTAGE BUT CERTAINLY
GAINING MOMENTUM ON THIS ISSUE.
>> Jesse: GLENN YOUNGKIN IS AN
DeSANTIS IS.
AND SHE IS WARMING UP TO ME OR
I'M WARMING UP TO HER.
>> Greg: IT COULD BE BOTH.
>> Jessica: SHE DEFINITELY IS.
>> Jesse: THE SCHOOLS HAVE
LOST THEIR MISSION.
PEERLESS
HSE JR. TRIES OUT FOR THE
FOOTBALL TEAM.
INSTEAD OF DOING TACKLING DRILLS
AND SEVEN ON SEVENS, SEPARATES
THE BLACK PLAYERS FROM THE WHITE
PLAYERS AND IT MAKES THE LINEMAN
WHO CAN'T CATCH PLAY
WIDE RECEIVER AND SPENDS THE
REST OF THE PRACTICE MOANING
ABOUT HOW THE GIRLS ARE NOT ON
THE POST ENDEMIC FOOTBALL TEAM.
DO YOU THINK THAT TEAM WILL HAVE
ANY FUN OR THE PLAYERS WILL PLAY
FOOTBALL?
NO!
THAT IS WHAT THEY HAVE DONE.
THEY HAVE LOST THE MISSION.
PEOPLE LIKE GLENN YOUNGKIN OR
PRESENT ADVANTAGE BECAUSE THE
PARENTS ARE THE CUSTOMERS.
THERE IS AN OLD SAYING THAT THE
CUSTOMERS ALWAYS RIGHT.
HE WAS CRAFTY HOW HE SAID IT,
JUST LISTEN TO THE PARENTS.
HE DOESN'T WANT THE PARENTS TO
BE ANNOYING AND STARTS GROWING
AROUND IN THE CLASSROOMS AND
ANOINTED TEACHERS.
HE SAYS ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
TEACHERS ARE SAYING, YOU CAN'T
AFFORD TO SEND YOUR KID TO
PRIVATE SCHOOL.
WE GOT YOU BY THE YOU KNOW WHAT.
WE OWN YOUR CHILD AND HAVE YOU
SEEN HOW MUCH MONEY YOUR
PROPERTY TAXES ARE QUESTION
MARKS WE ARE PAYING SO MUCH
MONEY AND PROPERTY TAXES FOR
SCHOOLS WHERE THE TEST SCORES GO
DOWN AND THAT HAS TO CHANGE
>> Dan